hey good afternoon thank you that's a
good idea
odd to think about that any suggestions
Thanks you know yeah I mean there's a
lot of great people nominated this year
I wish Tom Hanks was in there that's
kind of crazy that he's not like to hang
out with him I don't know how to answer
that question because it would be it to
me it's just the obvious and it would be
hard not to I mean I you know I get to
do the things that I dreamt of as a kid
you know to be working now with Clint
Eastwood about to do this other movie I
mean I'm absolutely living the dream and
if you want to work twice with David
O'Russell and Cameron Crowe in the fall
I mean it's a it's like I can't believe
it and to be able to be a part of this
kind of thing two years in a row I mean
I just keep waiting for her to take me
away and say I'm sorry so what are you
doing here
and you know maybe it's the way I was
raised III don't know how to answer that
I can only speak from my own experience
yeah thanks